las escuelas tienen temarios y tienen
métodos de evaluación y sólo avanzas en
grados cuando has terminado el anterior
como entra khan academy en este
escenario como encaja con los temarios y
los métodos de evaluación actuales bueno
esta es mi opinión y me parece algo
presionante ahora pensamos que los
estudiantes van a su propio ritmo y no
avanzan en los temas hasta no haber
aprendido los previos es como decir que
se puede correr hasta que sea dominado
caminar considerar estas ideas nos lleva
a los fundamentos básicos de la
educación realmente tienes que separar a
los jóvenes de los grupos de acuerdo a
su grado pues tenemos el caso de esta
escuela en los ángeles en la escuela
amar verdad donde están trabajando
estudiantes de entre séptimo y doceavo
grado estudiando diferentes temas
tenemos desde algunos estudiando cálculo
otros pre álgebra y están todos
conviviendo en el mismo espacio y los
estudiantes mayores ayudan a los menores
y ahora el maestro es un fascinador que
está asistiendo a cada uno de los
estudiantes en su propio nivel ayudando
a que ya no es el modelo de una clase
observando hacia el frente y tampoco es
el concepto de un maestro
para 30 estudiantes un maestro para 30
estudiantes qué tal si ahora tenemos
tres maestros para 90 estudiantes que
pueden estar ayudando a diversos
estudiantes es esa la escuela del futuro
sí sí yo creo que podríamos revisar cómo
funciona el espacio escolar es decir la
escuela debe de ser un espacio donde
puedas aprender todo lo que quieras en
cualquier momento virtualmente y el
espacio físico debe de ser tal que los
estudiantes asistan augusto y tengan una
red de soporte para aprender lo que era
y así quisiera ver la escuela del futuro
y en especial para mis hijos me gustaría
que si mis hijos quisieran asistir a la
escuela
los fines de semana pudieran hacerlo o
tal vez en el verano o qué tal si entro
tengo que dar una conferencia en londres
y mejor me acompañan y aprenden de esa
experiencia y no perderían las lecciones
porque podrían observar las pre en línea
y ahí pueden acceder a las lecciones